اسلحه وتقنيات جديده مختلفه تختبرها
اسرائيل على قطاع غزه من ضمنها منظومه
صواريخ تستخدم لاول مره واجهزه رصد وتنصت
ومتابعه ذات تقنيه تكنولوجيه عاليه هذا ما
كشفته مصادر عسكريه في تل ابيب والتي قالت
ايضا ان الجيش حرص على استخدام هذه
الوسائل في العمليه العسكريه المسماه
السهم الواقي ضد الفصائل الفلسطينيه في
غزه المنظومه الصاروخيه الدفاعيه مقلع
داود من ابرزها فهو نظام قصير ومتوسط
المدى لاسقاط الصواريخ وجزء من الدرع
الصاروخي لاسرائيل الذي يشمل نظام القبه
الحديديه تصميم وتطوير مقلاع داود نفذته
شركات اسرائيليه وامريكيه مختصه بانظمه
الدفاع المتقدمه فيما كشفت صحيفه يدي عود
احرنوت ان تكلفه اطلاق الصاروخ الواحد من
مقلاع داوود تبلغ مليون دولار
[موسيقى]